foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the Dragon update video in this
video I want to go over some of the new
information regarding House of the
dragon's second season for those of you
who don't know there's been a lot of
activity on how so the dragon set while
they're filming one of the major battles
that will be featured in the new season
as we all know this new season of House
of the Dragon will show us what happened
during the beginning of the dance of the
Dragons when House Targaryen went the
war with their own family over the Iron
Throne one of the major events from the
dance of the Dragons will be the battle
at rook's rest now according to what
George R Martin wrote in Fire and Blood
this was when sir Kristen Cole devises a
very aggressive strategy for attacking
Rainier's allies in addition to dragons
King aegon and Sir Kristen Cole marched
out of King's Landing with a hundred
nights 500 men at arms and over 1500
sell swords after forcing the submission
of rosby in stokeworth they force them
to add their strength to aegon's own
host giving them roughly 3 000 Men by
the time they made it to dusken Dam well
Lord Stanton shut the gates of rook's
rest but he was unable to stop sir
Kristen Cole from burning his fields or
killing his small folk and livestock now
this is when Lord Staunton reached out
for assistance from rhaenyra Targaryen
by sending a raven to Dragonstone nine
days later it was actually rainey's
Targaryen and her Dragon melees who
arrived above rook's rest to a lord
Stanton however sir Kristen Cole was
ready for this and he had his archers
and scorpions fire at melees now the
dragon was largely unharmed by the
Ambush and she responded by burning
Christian Soldiers with dragon fire
melees was then attacked by King aegon
atop his Dragon Sunfire and his brother
aemond atop his massive Dragon vagar the
aerial combat between the two dragons of
the greens and the one Dragon of the
black saw the death of rhaenys and her
Dragon melees aegon suffered severe
burns however and Sunfire was rendered
flightless from the fight with melees
that's when aemon sir Kristen Cole and
the surviving greens took rook's rest
and and killed Lord Staunton and his
Garrison of 100 Soldiers the loss of
rhaeny's Targaryen and her Dragon melees
was a severe blow to the blacks rhaeny's
husband the sea snake Corliss valerion
was unraged and he blamed her death on
rhaenyra Targaryen stating that if her
or her sons had gone with their dragons
his wife might still be alive today
afterwards the heads of Lord Staunton
and melees were taken to King's Landing
now if you've been watching my videos
then you already know HBO has filmed
that scene we've already seen many
videos and photos of melee's head
getting dragged through the streets of
King's Landing
[Applause]
[Music]
the whole
thank you
now HBO's in the middle of filming the
battle scenes of rook's rest there are a
number of new photos and videos that
have leaked out from the set this
morning in fact sir Kristen Cole in
gawaine Hightower have been spotted on
set today while filming their scenes
unfortunately some of these videos were
not filmed in high definition but you
can still see they're setting things up
for the major battle there's Lannister
Targaryen and Hightower soldiers
everywhere you should be able to see
some of their Weaponry as well here's a
new video of some of those stunt men
getting ready to film while using these
weapons
come on guys
here's also another video of the
Lannister soldiers getting ready on the
day before the major battle was filmed
Jason Lannister is in the scene as well
and I also want you to see some of the
various sites set up around the set in
one of these videos you can see they're
roasting an animal over what will be an
open fire here are some higher
definition photos of some of the
soldiers on set now you can get a good
idea of who will be there during the
major battle at rook's rest director
Alan Taylor was also on set which lets
me know the battle should happen in the
middle of the Season most likely during
the fifth episode like I said at the
beginning of this video this battle will
be one of the major events from the new
season not only will it affect how many
dragons are left in the show but it's
also going to affect who is sitting on
the Iron Throne now since the battle was
happening outside I'm sure we will see
some more photos and videos leak from
the set it's obviously very hard to hide
what you're filming when you're outside
like this I will make sure to keep all
of you up to date whenever I receive any
new information regarding this scene or
anything else revolving around House of
the Dragon second season make sure you
subscribe now so you don't miss any of
my new uploads as always I want to thank
all of you for watching another video I
hope all of you have a great day I will
see you again very soon bye
[Music]